طرح الرئيس السوداني المعزول عمر البشير
امام المحكمه اليوم روايه حول انقلاب
العام
1989 تناقض رواياته السابقه التي تحدث بها
ونشرتها العربيه بشكل حصري في وثائقي
الاسرار الكبرى الذي بث في ديسمبر عام
روايه البشير اليوم جاء فيها اعلانه تحمل
المسؤوليه الكامله وحده عن انقلاب العام
89 ولم يشترك معه اي مدني الرئيس المعزول
قال ان الانقلاب كان مبنيا على دستور
العام 65 المعدل والذي حمل القوات المسلحه
مسؤوليه حمايه البلاد مشيرا الى ان مذكره
الجيش للحكومه حينها كشفت حجم الضعف
والنقص الذي تنعانيه القوات المسلحه
لكن عايز اثبت حقيقه مولانا
انه كله يا اخواننا اعضاء مجلس الثوره
الموجودين هنا
في هذه القاعه
ما كان عندهم اي دور
في التخطيط او التنفيذ
وانما تم اختياره كوكب من خير الضباط
القوات المسلحه
في اي مدينه دخل معنا
عامل عسكري بحث
الجيش حينها في بيت الضيافه زاعما انه حين
زارهم باركوا تحركه واستلامه للسلطه عازيا
انقلابه الى الاوضاع العامه السيئه في
البلاد والتي كانت السبب الحقيقي
سابقا خلال الاعترافات التي بثتها العربيه
في وثائقيات حصريه تغنى فيها بسيطره تنظيم
الاخوان على مفاصل الدوله اي انه عمل منظم
وليست تصرفا فرديا كما الذعه
الاخوان
التعليم
جماعه الاخوان للسلطه بالطريقه التي
يقررونها وكيف تتم عمليات التسلسل الهرمي
والسلطويض داخل الجامعه سرا
كبير جدا
الحركه الاسلاميه
لعندك انت جبته في اجتماع ان احنا ضباط
ومقرروا السلطه ما سالنا اخوان
علشان بدي اكسر الحركه يا قررت ولما قررت
نحن نقنع
فبعدها 30 عاما من الحكم خرجت اسرار
التنظيم الاكثر سريه في العالم تنظيم
الاخوان وتحدث مسؤوله بالصوت والصوره بما
راوا ان السلطان سيدوم والسري ستبقى في
الوثائقيات الحصريه التي بثتها العربيه
تحدث البشير ونائبه علي عثمان طه وقاده
كثر في التنظيم عن تدبيرهم انقلاب يونيو
وتمكينهم لانفسهم وحرمان الاخرين هو بطشهم
الان هي دوله المشروعه الاسلاميه التي يجب
المحافظه عليها
تموت خياران وجهتنا منصبا للم
حافظه والتقريتها في احتفاله المنصه
الاولى
التي تزيل مسروعه وتجمع
نائب الرئيس السوداني المعزول علي عثمان
طه بالصوت والصوره يشير الى ان جماعه
الاخوان كانت المتحكمه والحاكم الفعلي
السوداني وان حزب المؤتمر الوطني كان مجرد
واجهه للاخوان لا اكثر اليوم
ظهر البشير بمظهر المتحدي الزاعما
مسؤوليته عن انقلاب 89 لكن ما كشفته
وثائقيات العربيه يناقد روايات البشيره
الجماعه كانت الامر الناهي في السودان
وليس الرجل وكان الانقلاب مدبرا ومخططا
بشكل وثيقه
انا بولا بالصوت العالي ويشاركني في هذا
معظم يا اخواننا ان لم يكن جميعهم في
اللجنه لانه بالمعطيات التي كانت قائمه في
89 لو عاد التاريخ القهقره فاثناء نجف نفس
الموقف
بالتغيير الذي حدث في